[Musique]
bonjour bonjour mais je trouve qu'on n'a
pas tellement grand chose devant nous
aujourd'hui on a vu mieux évolué au plus
haut mais on a du bon on a du vent on a
du banc pas énorme comme quantité
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
faire avec ça a alors on va faire des
filets de truite saumonée au beurre de
bronze citronnée raconter sa version
présentée non pas du tout vous devriez
indri un peu moderne et romantique et
romantique points mais saint rené quand
même la rose dans un plat ça paraît
bizarre alors qu'est ce qu'il faut quand
même parlons sérieusement
voilà alors il faut un bon vin blanc
vendue l'argent c'est du grand art voilà
très bon il nous faut de l'eau de rose
voilà les l'eau de rose pour moi c'était
pour nettoyer la peau des bébés
et bien alors on va le joaillier notre
intérieur avec ça et ça ira très je suis
très sceptique et nous font du blé
il nous faut de la ventrèche il nous
faut de deux sortes de citron du vert et
du jaune
il nous faut bien entendu une très belle
truite qui est très fraîche très bon
créneau d'entraînement ont été gardés à
dire elle est quand même là les ouïes
bien volontiers
voilà très joli mais dites moi c'est une
truite saumonée alors est ce que vous
savez pourquoi ils sont devenus souvent
mais votez pour moi c'est parce que son
rôle prépare qu'elles ont fauté un peu
dans les eaux ne s'agit pas les voir en
championnat
je ne suis pas curieuse je pars ce
courriel titré du pas bon ça nous est
égal salaire égal très bien les 6 jours
6 et 10 6 attendra de la truite de toros
et surtout c'est finalement une grosse
d'un truc voilà bon si vous avez là bas
tout ce qu'il nous faut habituellement
oui et puis du cresson produit pendant
les humeurs puis alors là il veut des
avoués parlé tout à l'heure de choses
surprenantes allongé mais je vois qu'on
appelle l'art de décoration bien ce
n'est pas pour voir faut pas rêver le
réalisateur n'a pas offert ces robots -
non c'est parce qu'on a préfère on a
plus de légumes et on va les manger
sache que par orange le poisson orange
prévoit la suppression des rails un peu
on va on va voir là où il faut toujours
essayer
alors pour commencer qu'est ce que vous
allez faire jouer vis de la truite est
levée le filet on pourrait le faire
faire par le poissonnier comme oui mais
nous on a besoin de l'art est bon et
puis c'est rien à faire en sorte sollima
rien à faire un peu le ferait mais
dites-moi la venaison en a déçu
vous les garder il ya des gens comme ça
oui pour la 1ère c'est beau c'est
magnifique et bien sûr et on va faire
les filets maintenant je la connaissais
pas la tête je crois que c'est plus de
cet incident
parce qu'on peut suivre davantage la
rioja voile et oracle de plus possible
voilà ça va aller très bien
ouais voilà je vois bien la mort si
c'est la nourrice à 1
mais bien sûr et on va faire le second à
la une couleur devrait soulever des
nouvelles on lui a quand même et vos
marques toulon m'arrête
voilà parfait
voilà c'est bon aller très bien elle
arrête on va s'en servir
vous n'allez quand même pas me demander
de coucher ses belles roses sur du
poisson mais pourquoi pas rose voilà
l'art est l'élément-clé respirer puis
c'est trop tard oh on enlève à vous
annoncer
et voilà on les plante non mais c'est
pas si facile qu on croyait la la
l'important c'est la rose l'important de
favori ce que vous allez chercher votre
cb voilà en extrême orient ce possible
le voyage beaucoup en sont oui si vous
aviez manger de la soupe aux capucines
évidemment au cap la salade de capucine
delà du potage avec des violettes
voilà ce que vous devrez ainsi de suite
et ainsi de suite non nous avons évité
ou alors c'est pas fini d'avoir alors je
vais salez et poivrez
mon fidèle
là il reste alors je vais y mettre la
rave a piqué la tête piquée de roches
vertes en mai 36 quand même quelque
chose m'avait parlé du citron oui je
vais faire un jeu très bien merci
micheline hockey ce que je me fait
bander
voilà alors le citron on va faire des
petites julienne avec la poudre 6e rang
des zestes oui mais aurait une petite
juliette envolées verbales et les couper
faut s'amuser kahn apparaît très bien
voilà il ne faut pas des masses mais en
faisant foi c'est quand même un voulait
que je continue un peu pendant que vous
allez disposer sa tactique non il faut
que je les mettais comme ça vous à
l'extérieur découpe un petit morceau
abattant des jeux vous continuez qui
parle évidemment je vais couper
voilà voilà
alors on les prend or in j'avais un truc
tout fait pour étouffer ou fin d'une ère
ça va donner un bon goût up s'échappe at
all larose
c'est pas comme ça dans la chanson quand
même à la voilà on s'est bien passé vous
croyez en ac oui parce que ça se donner
beaucoup de goules et ensuite
ensuite je vais remettre mon autre fils
est là dessus et vous allez me demander
un flat italie allons à même de l'huile
et va le voir à la généreuse salir
poivre et qu'elles sont sans but
voilà je n'agis mettre de l'huile au
fond où vous avez mis pour enjoliver
surnom bien sûr un peu de graves blanc
ne sais pas voilà pas beaucoup et justes
dans la forme est là et ensuite je vais
prendre notre 8ème détendent et voir et
à four moyen avez-vous vie pendant 20
minutes là parce que c'est très vite par
vincent hugron l'un très bien et bien
parfait et pendant ce temps il va
falloir préparer la sauce à la roja la
rose fait ce que vous appelez le
bordereau citronnée et si lui y compris
alors faites-vous et ouvre enfin m je
prends mon citerons que je veux vous
serrer dans vos photos sur la casserole
parce que ce serait selon vous l'aviez
un peu trop chauffé à blanc non mais
c'est pas grave il vaut mieux voilà
alors je vais mettre tous les citrons
c'est à dire 3 2 sacs votre casserole la
non explosées l'ordre oui j'avais baissé
voilà c'est merveilleux
alors voyons résumons nous avons mis
trois filtres e36 jaune pour commencer
alors maintenant deux verres oui non si
on est beaucoup plus acides
ça va faire un bon mélange
heureusement que vous avez de la poigne
dans l'hymne
c'est ça les a sauvés c'est vous aimez
la ferme pas il faut bien on sait pas
combien va faire il faut bien mais moi
j'aime pas du tout il est un peu plus
dure
allez voir l'afrique alors à laudun je
vais y mettre de l'eau petit peu de
sucre un petit du sucre mais pas de
celle qu'on aime
non non non ja je suis comme de petites
percées dessus que je pense que ça ira
voilà on nous ferait après 210 litres
d'eau un petit peu d'eau ce projet qui a
pris l'eau de l'eau de rose
et puis qu'ils sont drôlement la rosée
olalalala sa main alors pareil même
volume bien assez je vais monter le gaz
pour que ça bout et maintenant une
hausse quand est ce que le temps que ça
bouge toujours le lire on va s'occuper
du lille et qu'est ce que vous en faites
vie je vais le faire brûler lieu
l'apéritif voie la plus usuelle du sud
ouest le bordelais bordeaux est à
l'honneur entre le vin de graves et le
lille et c'est merveilleux
bon alors là je vais monter tout aussi
odeurs robert alors je vais mettre tout
doucement
petit à petit beurre qui est bien
ramolli et vous allez tout y est et je
vais vous devez vous allez me le mettre
sur tous les jours salle et vous voilà
les petites noix peu à peu de beurre
frais bière et ça fait très joli tout ça
mais il faut la passeure de monter ce
qui provoque de lille est bourré c'est
bien parce qu'ils co qui réduit 6 e
rallye vous mettiez le foot perd toute
norme dans le caveau mulet
ça va mais bon ma sauce est prête
il me reste plus qu'à ajouter le millet
qui a grandement réduit
voilà ça me va le mener à l'euro très
bien je prends ma toile jeu là mais vous
allez voir pourquoi sur le feu
là c'est bon et je la reine où il
voulait arrêter je l'avais qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire un c'est pas avec des
nuits alors cette poêle avec de l'huile
je prenais rose puisque nous en sommes
rose sans vainqueur il ya deux ans à
l'étoile royaume par abel et jeu mais
c'est peut être de rose bien étaler
d'amap one voilà tchitchao de chaque
côté lassansaa livia
issaly pauvres voilà mais vous inquiétez
pas mais ça c'est excellent ah oui vous
essayez de toute évidence apparaît très
drôle voilà allez c'est bon mais rose
ses bottes n'aura plus qu'à présenter le
plat il y aura pu présenter là je vais
dire mettre mes roses et là dedans dans
cette assiette l on change de couleur et
on va présenter le plat la truite appui
25 minutes à four moyen ne paraît bien
méritée et les belles allait bien alors
qu'elle est bel et bien on va dresser le
plat alors on va mettre nos rose dessus
voyez comme ceux ci au jour dans
l'hérault
oui qui sont parce que certaines fruits
et on sortait pour aller voilà nos
agents mais un tout petit peu ça fasse
jolie vieille est tous à la halle et la
bonne chose parce que je vous assure que
c'est réfère ce qu'implique suez je
récoltais distinctement sans que
personne ne me vois je peux vous assurer
que c'est bon et bien alors allons-y là
les canadiens seraient ravis parce qu'au
canada il von toute la cuisine avec des
fleurs
moi j'ai mangé les capucines des
violettes et tout ça pourquoi pas des
roses voilà voilà
donner des idées alors si vous avez
envie d'essayer de faire comme maïté de
vous mettre à manger des fleurs la
truite à la rose pourquoi pas un séjour
vous nous donnerez des nouvelles
au revoir à bientôt bon appétit à
bientôt
[Musique]